very good luck for the San Francisco
49ers on Sunday the the stunner of the
day really because the the 49ers
operating on a short week them Rams were
desperate this was the if you don't win
this game you are screwed especially
this relates to trying to win your
division right and the Rams
who had lost two games four days apart
and they had they sounded great all the
cliches everything you know this hey
three and two or three and two two years
ago and everything worked out well it
didn't work out they got shut down
offensively by the 49ers we get so
caught up in the offense of the 49 that
defense is pretty good they're special
the defense it really is Robert Sala I
mean everything he's doing on that side
of the ball they dominated up front and
this is something I know we've talked
about a little this 49ers front though
it's got everything speed size power
depth so they're there like we talked
about any great defense you know when it
comes time to play Tom Brady in the
Super Bowl or any other team like that
they're gonna be able to get home with
their front four and they absolutely
smothered and just ran over the Rams
offensive line and made Jared Goff a
non-factor and the running game a
non-factor and I mean 49ers mighty you
could argue the best team in the NFL I
know we got a long way to go right on
Super Bowl but I am so rooting for 49ers
patron would that be amazing Jimmy G
versus Tommy Tommy and his home towns
home to the team that he was at the
catch game you haven't heard about some
time here yes from Detroit you know that
yeah it would be an incredible matchup I
would love to talk about that for two
weeks Tom Brady would not love to have
to get away from that front four because
that's the formula yes because you get
pressure up the middle you rush him and
you force him to get rid of the ball
more quickly
I got run aground yeah and and I don't
know how much not having Todd Gurley
affected the Rams you know I had someone
arguing with me last night that the
threat of Gurley allowed the 49ers to
play a little bit differently that even
though Girly's not a workhorse anymore
right when he's on the field you have to
account for he wasn't on the field they
weren't scared by Malcolm Brown they
weren't scared by Darrell Henderson and
they were able to focus on Jared Goff
Jared Goff my god 13 to 24 for 78 yards
I said
last
on the radio the last time I saw a
supposed franchise quarterback with
those kind of numbers that was when the
Broncos shut down the Packers four years
ago on Sunday and that was the moment
where it first looked like this Broncos
team may have something that could carry
them to the Super Bowl this 49ers team
looks like it may have something they
may carry it to the Super me I agree and
you know hey this Todd Gurley make a
difference I don't really think so
yesterday in that game I don't because
it wasn't like we know we just talked
about the the the Rams old line got
steamrolled and then they lost their
starting left guard and a Joseph
Noteboom who got hurt pretty badly and I
just think from that standpoint on the
49ers didn't have to compromise anything
they were doing in the in the past
coverage department because of their
ability just to overpower them up front
but man well you just talk about Bosa
Dee Ford Armstead
you know DeForest Buckner and then you
get into their backups I mean when you
have backup Salomon Thomas is the number
three pick of the draft and he's coming
off the bench and other guys like that
pretty impressive and yeah the 49ers I
mean just what they've done at this
point it's it's an impressive resume I
think they're certainly the best team in
the NFC right now now I mean the Saints
are I would I get you I think that would
be a great showdown but I don't see a
weakness to this 49ers team your guy
Kyle Shanahan and Sean Payton the coach
of the Saints I think are neck-and-neck
for Coach of the Year through six yeah
because what Peyton's done without Drew
Brees is remarkable but with College
what Cal shayna has done with that team
is incredible and yes I saw some quotes
from him when I wrote about this Friday
night he was almost gleeful to have the
challenge of not having his starting
tackles and do not have his fullback
yeah that this is what footballs about
and this is what I like I like having to
adapt I like having to adjust he does
like having to get my guys ready and
come up with different ideas when I know
that there's somebody that that you know
isn't going to be available to me right
that's what he relishes about coaching
in the NFL and I guess I should have
seen it coming yeah I mean yeah III hear
you too I mean I picked the Rams I'm so
because I thought the 49ers of those
injuries and the Rams being desperate
and having a long week I thought ooh
they'll win a real close one here but
you know obviously we were wrong and
Kyle is as creative as it gets on the
offensive side of the ball that's that's
really something that
we've all seen really even back of his
days as being the offensive coordinator
the Houston Texans yeah I mean here's a
story of how creative it is all right he
did Robert Griffin
you know Robert Griffin they draft him
with his number-two pick with these
Washington Redskins and I know he's up
late one night and he's stressing out
cuz he's gonna you know I'm gonna start
a rookie quarterback what am I gonna do
he's got this special skill set and you
know he like basically it kept him up
and he went down in the kitchen like in
the middle of the night and just started
like drawing on napkins and things and
basically came up with that offense but
that's that's Kyle he's always thinking
about football and he's one of those
guys out there and there's not a lot of
them Sean Payton being one of them Doug
Peters and although he can match the
wits and the aggressiveness of a Bill
Belichick if they came down to a Super
Bowl not saying he's you know in a match
um you know toe-to-toe but be very close
or certainly not be blown out to where
that's a huge favor or a huge advantage
for the New England Patriots and that
that's why Kyle's awesome week 14 Oh
49ers Etzel that could determine home
the 1 seed yeah right where the rematch
would potentially be if it comes down to
it and look the Rams aren't done yet
No 3 and 3 with the Seahawks at 5 and 1
yes and the 49ers at 5 and OH
good luck climbing to the top of the
division yet I think the divisions about
almost unreachable I mean for the Rams
right it's to that point and let's
assume yeah as I think we should that
one of those two teams 49ers and
Seahawks is gonna win the division right
the other team is gonna be the 5 seed of
the 6th seed yeah look at the NFC North
yeah you've got look you you you you'd
be in last place at 3 and 3 right now in
the NFC North yeah
the Rams all of a sudden have to start
worrying about not making it to the
playoffs and you and I both thought the
Rams and the Saints would make it to the
playoffs maybe we'll be right about one
of those two because the Rams have lost
their way
yeah I don't know you know this is like
changing the tire on a moving car and
and there's so much optimism that you
hear and it's cliche at a certain point
you're just not getting it done
yeah and I feel like the Rams aren't
getting it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports